who's Randy don't bring anyone love into
this no more motherfucker said okay I
got to tell you this because normally we
don't do this okay
normally when when we have like a shirt
launch we've had a few in recent weeks
completely normal came back to Netflix
so we did we released a new version of
sub Cain as like a celebration where I
partnered with dos Brack I think I don't
know how to say his name rate on
Instagram he's a great artist and then I
we did mu soup because it was so timely
but then we got this unbelievable
submission for a shirt design and I have
to make sure I say correctly the credit
for it so this shirt design was so funny
that I was like yeah we we absolutely
have to to do that and the guy's name
here we go is a mark glass so he's
totally glass in mark glass
he has let's see designed by humans calm
he did rah rah rah
oh the rub rub rub shirt I've seen I
laughed so hard at this design that I
was like we were just going to put it up
so it's up there if you go to merge
method calm are you serious
we made this shirt yeah immediately oh
my god yeah
and how would you describe it I'd prefer
not to
um well no you go ahead this is well it
says it says of course the the great
phrase rubber I'll up Robin rap and this
has my face and it looks like my eyes
are struggling to stay open because I'm
in ecstasy and it looks like something
on it dripping off
of the face there yeah that's good hey
it's your call I mean if you want the
shirt around Corsa would come dripping
from your beard we might get babe
that's what it is you'd be more
appreciative I am I think it's really
neat thank thank you Mark for doing that
thanks mark and I just wanted to give
you a shout out you think they make them
in t2 the size of our Sun babe your kid
wants to wear that rap right can I tell
you something else that happened we
actually had the rubber up guy cut
together with Kim in the grapes man or a
little audio fun do you want to hear
what the two of them either yeah
Kim an of course if you don't know is a
one of the great adult performers of all
times and she and the Rev Rev guy are
both Asian and we decided they're both
sexual people what would happen if we
see them together yes well we've never
we do what I was gonna say that we've
been working on the blue bands been
working notice because we had the idea a
few weeks ago you were sitting down and
we thought wouldn't it be a power couple
if you will the two of them to them are
perfect yeah to to the grade this is
like what it would be like if the two of
them met and and did some work together
to blue bin and put this together
whenever we do the scene we always fuck
hot aren't we ancient sinks and you get
the oil in my hand and you rock Hank
already ruff ruff ruff ruff and what you
need to do is be mindful about your
spine especially in the vagina
especially on the campaign is rubber you
need to start judgment from right along
pretty Pam one one right side 50 times
left side you come from
with the combat this is how about this
cause being my type asian pussy there
you go that's beautifully good better
than I expected
yeah so it's a great man waiting for
that now you have Kim in a rock rum
really special right what's his name I
looked it up it's uh it's not Kyle I'll
tell you that it's different
[Music]